two
and you'll be hearing a little bit from
Dr Sandeep Shukla some comments he made
on a previous edition of this webinar so
he'll take you through
the
blockchain
ecosystem and why it's an important part
of your career opportunities going
forward
today we'll be talking a little bit
about you during some poll questions for
the audience keep an eye out for those
if you happen to be on our
streaming services the YouTube live or
LinkedIn live please enter your
responses to the polls and questions in
the
um
chat or comment box of your streaming
service we'll try to get to those that
applies to the Q a if you are on zoom
and you have questions you'd like me to
answer please put those in the Q and A I
will get to those at the
end of the webinar
um again as I said Dr Shukla will talk
about blockchain and I'll speak about
what this program offers how it gets
your job ready when we go into the
enrollment steps I'll mention a bonus
offer for all of you for being here this
evening so
let's get started
I'm going to
share with you
Dr shukla's comments
about the blockchain ecosystem
yeah so as most of you since you are
attending this you will probably have
heard what blockchain is and what uh
what blockchain is being used for one of
the of course common usage of blockchain
Technology came from cryptocurrency uh
Bitcoin ethereum Monero and Solana and
various other cryptocurrencies
however uh the technology that came out
of this development of this private
so-called private money in terms of
cryptocurrency
has already given us a number of
Technology Solutions that can be used
for other applications other than
cryptocurrency cryptocurrency is one
application of blockchain but blockchain
because we have this notion of smart
contracts and notion of immutable uh
decentralized Ledger and the idea of
privacy and idea of Integrity of data
and security and
the authentication uh therefore number
of different solutions has come up a lot
of solutions are related to uh
enforcing contracts across multiple
multiple different organizations
uh I guess the yeah and uh also supply
chain uh supply chain provenance
tracking and many other like as I
mentioned land record registry uh
identity uh there are various types of
credentials this kind of applications
have come up
uh so as per uh the market data it seems
that the compound annual growth rate of
blockchain Market is about uh is quite
remarkable 67.3 percent through uh the
year 2025
and also
the markets and markets predicts that
spending uh in in this technology will
jump to about 40 billion dollars in 2025
so basically what these numbers are not
important what is important is that this
is a growth sector of of a new
technology and it has gone through the
hype cycle and it is now at a point
where it is being deployed for various
kinds of solutions and therefore in the
next uh you know couple of years we'll
see a lot more growth and now we are at
the growth phase of the technology after
it has gone through high phases and and
various other phases
so so therefore uh we can uh we can
basically uh think of this as a good uh
technology uh that yeah one could gain
expertise in in order to actually have a
good career growth
okay so next slide
yeah so uh blockchain technology uh
actually requires quite a few different
uh Technologies uh to to be mastered of
course this is very much uh dependent on
cryptography and the notion of
cryptography is best Illustrated as
cryptocurrency
um cryptocurrency Solutions illustrate
how cryptography is very important in
blockchain
and Bitcoin is an example and Bitcoin is
actually the first blockchain that we
have seen and it has given us a very
good ideas about how to use Technologies
such as cryptography hashing algorithms
decentralized conferences uh this kind
of digital signatures this kind of ideas
together in a very clever technological
solutions and so Bitcoin is an important
component of learning in uh when we
learn blockchain we also see uh the dlts
the distributed Ledger technology which
is slightly different from standard
cryptocurrency blockchains uh
hyperledger would be an example of
distributed Ledger technology which is
actually is one form of blockchain
we also learn about ethereum as as it
grew from Bitcoin technology with the
ability to do smart contracts and
hyperledger also does Smart contracts
and also consensus mechanism is also
very important consensus is the way that
decentralized entities together make
decisions because we have to keep a
uniform view a consistent view of The
Ledger which is maintained across
multiple different entities who do not
necessarily trust each other so there
has to be a robust consensus algorithm
which is tolerant to at least a fraction
of
users such fraction of nodes not
behaving in a trustworthy Manner and
also networks and workflows and
transaction workflows Etc these are some
of the concepts that you have to learn
in in order to learn about
the blockchain technology next and the
kind of skills that one could actually
uh think about uh you know obviously you
will be learning this uh basic
fundamentals of Technology we will learn
various applications and our design
applications but the kind of job jobs
that you might actually find after
completing this kind of a course is
either as a blockchain developer if you
are very good in programming uh but if
you are also good in front-end
programming that is uh doing the web
design then you could also possibly
become a blockchain web designer which
is basically for Designing the front end
of the blockchain application uh you can
also become a blockchain solution
architect if you can gain a very good
understanding of multiple different
types of blockchain
and what kind of applications fit uh
what kind of blockchain Technology like
where uh a public blockchain fits where
a private blockchain fits where in uh uh
you know partition uh versus
permissionless blockchain fits uh which
ones require you to have more privacy
preserving transactions if you can
somehow uh can gain that understanding
uh different people have gain different
types of understanding from completion
of a course like this because they have
different interests so blockchain
solution architect would be one of the
one of the good ones that to to try to
become of course you can become
blockchain project manager where you
manage projects that are based on
blockchain technology you can also
become uh on a in the user interface
user experience designer for blockchain
in applications when the application is
quite complex and and requires different
types of interaction between the users
and the sys backend system uh you can
become a blockchain quality engineer
where you will be testing the blockchain
based Solutions and and providing uh
quality uh guidance and then you may
also go into blockchain legal Consulting
of course if you have also a legal
background
so as as was said that the industry is
growing very fast in blockchain and so
are the salaries so from The Glassdoor
Source uh the simply learn has learned
that the salary range could be as high
as 10 lakhs per second uh sorry per
month not per second
to about uh three lakhs per second uh
sorry per month uh in case of uh in case
of uh on the lower end uh so this is the
kind of salary range there is a median
salary or average salary is about about
six lakhs uh or five and a half lakhs
and different companies are hiring
especially I know personally people from
Accenture Oracle
Microsoft uh they're hiring in
blockchain uh technology uh so
blockchain technology is a very
technology uh solution architect
blockchain technology develop blockchain
application developer blockchain
front-end developer uh for a blockchain
project manager these are very very uh
very highly sought
skills uh in today's market
all right so you heard from uh Dr Shukla
who is the director of the Indian
national blockchain project at IIT
confer
I'll move forward through
so at this point I'd like to ask a
question of the audience uh all of you
out there what has stopped you so far
from taking
certification of this type
and if you're on the streaming services
you can put A B C or D into the comment
and
is it because you haven't found a
program that has the kind of curriculum
coverage all the skills Dr Shukla
mentioned is it
because you don't feel you would get
practical experience you could point to
to say you're job ready
is it because you don't find learning
from pre-recorded videos to be effective
for you or is it
because you don't have time in your work
schedule so
I'm going to leave this open for about
another 15 seconds as the numbers keep
changing
please do get your answers in
here I am going to end the poll in five
seconds
and here's the result
so the main two
difficulties for people in our audience
today are not finding a comprehensive
curriculum and not feeling you would get
experienced to demonstrate to employers
that you have job ready skills in the
field so let me
talk about this program IIT Khan poor
has developed this program
certify you in blockchain skills
uh it is a four-month program
completely online
see the base price is one lock sixty
nine thousand uh I will be talking later
about a bonus that you get for being
here at this webinar so
that in mind but also uh the curriculum
is completely comprehensive as as I will
go over with you it's aligned to the
needs of Industry one of the great
things about working with
industry for IIT Camp copper is that
they understand what industry requires
from their graduates and what skill sets
people need to succeed out in the work
world so they've designed this
curriculum
uh to meet that industry aligned
requirement the
learning environment provides everything
you need online both for your live
classes
with your instructors
as well as for your labs and projects
and other
cases that you're going to work on and
do to build up a portfolio of practical
experience you can demonstrate to
employers
you will be meeting with your
instructors live in online classes so
you get to interact with them ask them
questions they'll ask you questions
you'll be able to interact with your
batchmates in the class and
um
between the class sessions on the
weekends you'll be able to do all of
your other work on whatever schedule you
choose because the platform is available
24x7 on your desktop or laptop
want to look at the pre-recorded
materials that prepare you for each
class uh you can do even do that on your
mobile device so very flexible
commitment of about 10 hours a week
for the four months
Beyond
at the end of this you receive a
certificate from IIT Contour that
certifies that you have
completed the program successfully
gained the skills that it covers
you've had more than 70 hours of online
learning
between the live classes and the other
materials and you've done
four or more projects
um
including a Capstone project which I'll
describe in a bit but the Capstone
project will be your showpiece
putting your portfolio on a going
forward basis to show off
um and along the way you'll you'll have
master classes with IIT comport
professors who will uh
go uh Deep dive into some of the topics
here
but IIT Contour was established in 1959
and
is
uh the home of the Indian national
blockchain project so while the
institutions in the world this is one of
the very top
um
centers of expertise in blockchain
so the professional certification
program gives you access to that
expertise the master classes
Capstone project that will be your
showpiece again and the certificate uh
certificate that
demonstrates that IIT comp core has
put its Faith behind you
in your ability to do this work so
having that on your CV is a very
prestigious accomplishment people will
recognize
Institution
so eligibility you need to have
basic understanding of mathematics
and you should have
preferred that you have some experience
with Java programming
principles behind that um
you do need to have a bachelor's degree
with 50 marks or higher
but you do not have to have any formal
work experience so
this is a program that is for people
who've completed their bachelor's degree
have some exposure to math and
programming and want to become expert in
blockchain
so let me ask a question of the audience
again
this one is how much experience
do you have
launch this poll
pretty straightforward so I'll just
leave this open for about 20 seconds
and I'll close the poll in about five
seconds from now
here is the result
so a little more than half of our
audience are currently studying if you
are in your final year of studies
for your bachelor's degree and you will
be completed with bachelor's degree by
the time that this program ends you're
eligible to enroll
um otherwise you might want to um
hold off to a future cohort once you've
got your degree but for the rest of you
for the other 45 percent of the audience
um
it's like you have the
experience qualification certainly so
move on
talk about how this program prepares you
so the the program is designed to build
your blockchain skills in a stepwise
fashion that take you from the very
basics
to um or uh
expert level so you'll be moving from
the orientation session which is just to
get you uh
familiar with the learning management
system the set of courses that you'll be
taking how to interact with the system
and your instructors
all of the basics like a virtual
freshman orientation and then you'll
move into the introduction to the
technology behind blockchain
what what is a blockchain uh what are
the principles of
eligible indelible transactions and that
type of thing so then you'll move into
uh
ethereum
then you'll look at understanding
consensus and hash
uh
principles that underlie
recording of blocks you'll go into
hyperledger fabric smart contracts
uh uh Internet of Things applications
blockchain platforms and such
you move on to your um Capstone project
Epson project is a one month about three
to four week project
where you'll choose a problem
design your own solution your instructor
will Mentor you through the process
and that becomes your essentially your
final exam for the entire program
along the way you'll have access to uh
master classes from IIT com for faculty
these are electives you can choose to
attend or not but uh
if you are interested in the subject and
what's going on in terms of research and
development
you're a really great resource for you
you will need to learn and you will need
to use different
tools libraries platforms you'll need to
understand how they work you'll need to
be able to apply them in your projects
and once you are done with the program
and receive your certificate when you
talk about these on your CV you will be
able to say with confidence
that you understand them and know how to
use them
and have experience with them that you
can demonstrate through your portfolio
so this is really a wonderful part of
the program and the way it's organized
for learning by doing
we talk about the different kinds of
projects you might do
um
smart contracts doing a project to
develop smart contract applications so
you can see how that principle Works a
self-executing contracts a hyperledger
fabric
um
demonstrating that you know how to set
that up
learning about ethereum wallets
how to install them how to use them in
transactions so these are all kinds of
projects you'll be doing and then for
the Capstone project
you'll pick out of
several different industry domains
Financial Services or Healthcare
manufacturing where
you'll have a problem pose
that firm in this field wants to achieve
this with blockchain
how will you do that and as I said
you'll have three to four weeks to
design and build your solution
that you will then submit for grading
along the way you'll have your
instructor helping you to make sure you
don't counter doubts or blockers that's
that slow you down or stop you
successfully complete your Capstone
and at the end of the process
you'll have that Capstone in your
portfolio going forward so that you can
show it
to potential future employers or to your
current employer and say this is my new
set of skills this is how I've used them
this is my proof that I know how to do
this
a very valuable part of the program
and I'm going to let this gentleman talk
to you about
the learning platform itself
this is the reason why IIT conference
shows simply learned as the delivery
partner that he'll be going through an
example of one of our other programs
with a different University but the
use of the platform and the principles
are the same so
through this
welcome to Simply learn and our unique
online boot camp where millions of
professionals have gotten the skills
they need to succeed there are two
components that make our online boot
camp approach so successful great
content from the world's leading
technology companies practitioners and
universities and a unique and
proprietary learning environment that
was specifically designed for high
engagement and learner support when you
log into simply learn you set the course
timeline that meets your busy work and
home schedule and keep track of your
progress every step of the way we'll
help you stay on plan with automated and
24 7 human support at the core of our
programs are our live virtual classrooms
where you interact Real Time with
trainers that are recognized leaders in
their field there you'll review key
Concepts get questions answered and
interact with your peers the important
reports on the audience if you notice
are demographics this is super useful
especially if you're running ads for
example
social media marketing too
by looking at these numbers you will be
able to understand the age range of
people that you should be targeting you
know what you could just focus only on
that age category show your
advertisements to them very useful
that's not all you get to learn from
faculty at Global universities and
Industry experts via master classes ask
your questions to top industry leaders
in exclusive ask me anything sessions so
other another interesting question on
the chat box and say that oh to optimize
in YouTube you could use the rising
section of Google Trends and optimize it
okay so let's go back to here right here
where it says web searches and you can
see that there's going to be the YouTube
searches okay so now you can see that
the YouTube searches is going to be so
there's a option uh under not just web
search and there's going to be a YouTube
search okay so just go ahead and click
on YouTube search and you should be able
to optimize your search results
so what is Instagram app Instagram apps
refer to when we come across any sort of
original video
apps would appear within those video
contents so you will be caught when you
are watching an original video and leave
you a video app and then go back to the
original video content
we believe people learn best by doing go
beyond practice tackle practical
problems with multiple projects and
simulations and work on a real world
Capstone project that you can showcase
to Future employers your learning isn't
restricted to just live classes explore
our highly effective self-learning
videos and other resources to fine-tune
your learning and remain up to date
always you can focus on different
learning approaches by subject to
personalize the overall learning
experience to your learning style and
needs at the end of it all you get to
walk away with globally recognized
certificates from top universities for
the program leading companies for
specialized courses and simply learn so
come on in experience professional
learning like you've never done before
get started today
all right so you've seen just recap the
the learning environment and how it
allows you to manage your curriculum to
see all the courses that are ahead of
you guide you through them one by one
opens up the next course as soon as you
finish the one before that gives you a
certificate for the course you just
completed that unlocks the next course
and then the live virtual classroom
allows your instructor to take you
through the concepts live ask answer
your questions ask you questions go
through
exercises on their shared environment
you get to do labs and projects in your
virtual machine that's assigned to you
through the course so it's all done
through that same learning management
system same online environment
tests and assessments and the Capstone
project that we keep referring to
um
doing progress tracking and keeping
track of how you're progressing through
the program system will actually prompt
you if you
are beginning to fall behind and remind
you to catch up
so it helps it helps you succeed in that
way as well and you have support tools
that include a community where you can
ask your fellow students your
instructors other instructors questions
you can interact with your instructor
through the email system
and you have access to a 24x7 help desk
for both the issues with the platform
itself or subject matter questions
if you're working on a project at three
o'clock in the morning and you reach to
doubt or a blocker and you want to get
help with it you'll be able to reach out
to somebody and
get past that so
we're very proud of this learning
environment and again this is the reason
why IIT Contour shows simply learned as
a delivery partner and you'll be
learning from practitioners people who
work in the field who have solid
experience
people like vegard who
[Music]
do this work and are experienced
trainers as well so we want to make sure
that they're not only people who have
the knowledge and expertise in the field
but have the ability to communicate
those skills to you so
um and again
Dr Sundeep is uh
the
program director for this program but
he's also the coordinator of the
national blockchain project
so um and the end of the coordinator for
the interdisciplinary Center for cyber
security so uh he is one of the leading
uh figures in the field for these
emerging technologies that are so
important to the world today both
blockchain and cyber security
so proud to be working with him and he's
again supervising the curriculum and
delivery of the of the program
you can talk about some learner outcomes
at this point
I'll be getting to your questions uh
shortly so getting towards that point
uh people who you will be studying
alongside in your batch come from
different Industries
um interestingly Banking and Financial
is the predominant industry for people
who engage in this course
where many of our digital training
courses uh we take a larger share of
people from the I.T or software sector
in this case it's People Banking and
Financial Industries also distribution
and Manufacturing
infrastructure the public sector these
are all areas where
blockchain is
placed to transform
that industry or that sector and how it
works so this is why people from those
areas come into this course and people
from different companies um
not only these other sectors but also
IBM Accenture traffic consultancy so
you'll have exposure to a lot of people
from a lot of different backgrounds in
your batch
let's talk about the enrollment schedule
I'm promised to tell you about a bonus
for being here today
so if you enroll for the next cohorts
there are actually two starting just
about at the same time the orientation
on the 20th and I think another
orientation on the 21st classes starting
on the 11th of March or the 18th of
March so you have a couple of choices
with the next batch but you do want to
get in before the batch number of seats
fill up
and for being here today from that one
lock 39 000
uh price
we will offer you a 15 discount because
you attended this webinar
if you enroll for the
upcoming batches are coming up right
right away
um do you not have to pay off the entire
amount in one Fell Swoop financing is at
56 to 10. rupee a month that that would
be before the discount so it's actually
going to be 15 less than that uh for
being here today
and to get started
um share with you the enrollment steps
but before I do
now that you know what the program costs
and when it starts are you interested
based on everything you've heard so far
you answer that question
again based on what you've heard so far
is this something you'd like to do
and I'll give you another five seconds
to answer
and we'll share with you the result
so three quarters of our audience
is interested in enrolling in the
program the
wonderful and I'm going to share with
you how to do that so let's
move forward
steps are extremely simple
you email us and ask us at
simplylearn.net you can also contact us
through our
program page on our website and I'm
going to put that link also into
the chat right now both the program page
and the um
email address so bear with me as I put
that right now here
but in your chat
you now have
the program page
link and you have the
email address ask us simple learn.net
send us an application or you contact us
and we will help you through the
application
this involves reviewing your uh
degree making sure you have the
bachelor's degree that's required
um
any work experience that you might have
that you want us to consider
and a simple background or aptitude test
for
math and programming aspects of course
if you don't have those
math and programming
aspects in your background we can help
you gain those through some three
courses we offer as well so
help you pre-prepare for this course to
succeed so that's not a factor that
should stop you from contacting us
but once you email us we do the
application review we send you your
admission offer
and
get you started so for those of you who
said you are interested let me ask the
question how soon
do you see yourself starting
I'm going to take advantage of the 15
discount and start immediately
or are you looking further down the road
again I'll just leave this open for
another 10 seconds because
straightforward question
I will close the poll
three two
one
right
so more than fifty percent of our
audience wants to either start uh in the
March classes or uh maybe April May
just great again contact us and ask us
at simplylearn.net ask about the 15
discount if you're looking further down
the road please do contact us at ask us
at simplylearn.net and we'll answer any
lingering questions you have about the
program but we'll also be able to keep
you informed about future cohorts so
um
this point
I'd like to
go to questions and answers
so I'm looking again if you have placed
your question in the chat
please transfer it to the Q a because
it'll be much easier for me to find it
there apologize for that but
um
first question will we receive a
certificate of participation for
attending this webinar and I will share
that right after the Q a I'll tell you
how to get that
what are the fees of the program we've
talked about that
uh
session is almost over for those of you
who asked that question
um
whether blockchain will help you or
what's above and has asked whether
blockchain will help you in your career
if you're a person who wants to enter
into management consulting and um
the answer to that is yes because
as a Management Consultant
you will be asked the question how will
Technologies like blockchain affect
my business client is going to want to
know
what impact these new technologies will
have on their business understanding
that
is going to help you serve that client
better understanding that will also open
up opportunities for you to proactively
answer that question and look for
clients who are saying you have a need
or those types of changes
go to financial clients and talk and be
able to tell them about
um how blockchain is can be used in
their in their operations or legal
clients and talk to them about
how self-executing contracts will affect
them
that type of thing so it will not only
help you serve your existing clients
better but it will give you new avenues
to pursue clients
um
Commerce graduate project says Commerce
graduate I've done a chartered
accountancy are my skills okay for
completing this course uh
this product I assume you have a
bachelor's degree in your understanding
of the domain uh the finance and
accountancy World gives you a leg up on
other people gives you an advantage over
other people who um
may not have that domain background
you'll be able to understand immediately
how blockchain
Works within your domain and again as I
mentioned
to pick up the math and programming
skills required we can help you with
that if you don't have those already
uh
a question from uh attendee is it okay
if I know python that's certainly
adequate yeah
um
uh why only Java why not python solidity
you'll be using Java in the course more
than
um the other languages and
platforms so
that's why but again if you have the
experience with the others it will
be transferable you'll be able to pick
up the the necessary Java skills quickly
um
so Suresh Kumar uh is a diploma
qualification okay
you would have to ask the
learning consultant ask us at
simplylearn.net because
this is a postgraduate program you do
require a bachelor's degree
so you'll want to check with them to see
if there is a
dispensation or waiver
don't hold a bachelor's um oh we're
generally pretty strict on that I
apologize for that
um is there any AI course uh in this
program not really this is not oriented
towards Ai
and if you're interested in AI we have
you can ask our learning Consultants
about other programs that we have that
you might want to consider but if you're
interested in blockchain
nagamesh is very insistent about why
only Java I hope I've I've answered that
uh for you
Mahesh year um
if you have Python and solidity
background that will be fine
and
I apologize ivanesh I do not recognize
the the word you have used
your question
in the webinar itself no one is
answering the doubts how can we think
that this course is the best I apologize
if we haven't answered your questions
but again contact our learning
Consultants that ask us at
simplylearn.net and they will be able to
go deeper into your specific questions
one on one
um
naresh I am a fresher and I didn't have
any experience to is it okay to take
this course yes it is uh if you meet the
other requirements
um and how will blockchain make a career
for Refresher
again this is a new and emerging
technology
it's still if not in its infancy it's in
its childhood
it's going to be
important factor in so many different
Industries
that you're going to have opportunities
as an expert in the technology
to um be called on to help
lots of different
companies or lots of different functions
within a single employer so this creates
a great opportunity
for
people who want to get in at the
beginning of this industry
uh in Boston management consulting like
BCG Bain and McKinsey absolutely
management consultancies deal with
questions of blockchain all the time and
need to advise their clients so
uh this is a valuable skill in their
eyes
um can a person with another being asked
a person who's business analyst
non-technical background with 10 years
of experience
you should be able to succeed well in
this program it is not
so
strictly oriented towards technical that
you know you're training to be a
programmer you're actually training to
understand how the blockchain technology
Works in business as a business analyst
uh you again have the skills in the
background to be able to see those
connections
see how this technology will apply in a
business context so this gives you an
advantage
a basic knowledge required for learning
the blockchain goofy I think we talked
about that which is we prefer that you
have some understanding of mathematics
some exposure to Java programming again
we can help you with those if you don't
um you do need to have a bachelor's
degree one of the aspects of that is
showing that you have the
um background and
ability to commit to a long-term
learning program even though this is
only four months we want to make sure
that you're committed to it so that the
end of the four months you have
successfully completed it rather than
felt like it you haven't met up to it or
it hasn't fulfilled your needs
um is this an internship no this is a
training program we
um help you with in some cases with job
search uh assistance but that is not uh
we do not offer an internship or a
job guarantee or anything of that nature
and the last question here from dahar
says I do not have any previous
experience in software development will
it be possible for me to understand this
technology
and yes we just worked I I can
conference designed this program so that
it's accessible to you we will do the
initial assessment in your application
review
and give you a basic test on some of the
concepts so that if you take that test
and you say this makes absolutely no
sense to me whatsoever you may decide
this is not the program for you but
if you look at that and say oh no this
is pretty
understandable and I understand how to
do this type of thing
then you'll have the confidence that you
can succeed in this program so Our
intention is not to sign up every single
person who applies
and bail out
people who can't do the work Our
intention is to
review your application up front make
sure that you meet the prerequisites and
have the aptitude and the commitment to
succeed in the program
so the the end of the process
we're able to say that a high percentage
of our graduates have achieved their
goals right now Ernst young the
consultant from uh ey says that we have
a 90 rate of graduates saying that they
have
um met the the
goals that they had going into our
program so
we're extremely proud of that
um this is the last question I have in
our question and answer so I'm going to
move on to our final question our final
question for the audience
and
put that up on the screen
and this is if you are interested in a
certificate or participation for today
uh for this program for this webinar I
should say please
answer yes to this question we will send
you one but
if you need assistance or you want a
certificate for today
um
answer yes
and I'll leave this open just for about
10 seconds as it's a yes or no question
numbers keep changing
and I'll close it in three
two
one
and I'll show the results so it's fairly
even almost 50 50
and again if you've answered yes we will
uh
send you a proof of attendance
certificate for today's session
and
with that
I would like to thank all of you for
being here this evening
if you use the QR code it'll take you to
our the program page
but also ask us at simply learn.net will
take you to our learning consultant who
can answer your questions and if you if
I haven't answered anything that uh
still a doubt for you please do reach
out to ask us at simplylearn.net and if
they can help you with that
but in general we would like to invite
all of you to join us
in the Learning Community with IIT
contour and simply learn
and that concludes the webinar for this
season thank you again